if you're a Dark Souls fan then you're
probably familiar with some of publisher
Bandai Namco's other series like Naruto
Shippuden and Tekken and we've just
gotten a tease for what's coming next
I'm Tony and this is your mysterious
gamespot news update the teaser in
question hints at a new project the
anime looking video shows a bunch of
dark bloody imagery with some armored
characters and a huge beast that kind of
looks a bit like Ryu from death note it
all ends with the hashtag prepare to
dine which is weirdly similar to the
Dark Souls tagline prepare to die but
the word dying plus all the blood does
make me think of vampires you should
probably just subscribe so you can be
the first to know when Bandai Namco
reveals whatever this game is the Dark
Soul series is over for now and
blood-borne is owned by Sony so this
most likely isn't tied to either of
those properties still we should
hopefully learn more in the coming weeks
maybe a t-34 now you can watch more
monster slaying action in our Dragon
Quest heroes to combat preview
[Music]